I was in a relationship so I trust it
and you're in love that's what we did as
a couple privately somehow it became not
so private revenge porn is the act of
disseminating nude photos of an ex-lover
usually on the internet without their
permission scornful ex-lover seeking
revenge may find satisfaction in
revealing to the world private sexual
photos of those who broke their heart
that's exactly what Nicole of
Fredericksburg Virginia learned last
November the 25 year old nursing student
found a sexually explicit video of
herself on the Internet the video had
previously been sent by her to her
boyfriend of eight years however when
the relationship soured the intimate
video surfaced on a website dedicated to
revenge porn
Nicole's intimate video was now being
seen by hundreds of Internet users
including family friends and potential
employers at that point you know your
ass terrible and upset so then I called
the Fredericksburg police and nobody can
do anything the police could not
intervene because until recently it was
not illegal in Virginia to post photos
online which were legally obtained but
this year Virginia Idaho and Utah have
joined California and New Jersey in
criminalizing revenge porn 19 other
states have proposed legislation to do
the same and representative Jackie
Speier is looking to make it a federal
crime scorned lovers can now post
naughty pictures of you on the Internet
revenge porn has ruined many lives and
those photos often times never go away
but experts say it's a growing problem
this particular form of harassment is
something that's a new phenomena it's
growing
Virginia delegate Marcus Simon has
helped make revenge porn a crime in his
state his legislation House bill 49 was
incorporated into delegate Belle's House
bill 326 which makes revenge porn a
class 1 misdemeanor in Virginia
punishable by a fine and up to a year in
jail Governor Terry McAuliffe signed the
bill last month and will go into effect
this July so the legislation makes it a
crime in Virginia to disseminate
pictures of someone
in a state of undress so basically naked
pictures of someone without their
consent for the purpose of causing them
substantial emotional distress these are
pretty vague terms and when we're
talking about pure speech that should be
troubling Lee Rowland did the ACLU says
that while revenge porn poses serious
harms to victims Steve should be leery
of criminalizing it revenge porn
presents a really tricky issue because
what laws against revenge porn tend to
criminalize is the posting of an image
and that is pure speech posting an image
the Supreme Court's position rightly in
the ACL u--'s position is that all
speech is by default protected by our
First Amendment but simon argues that
the law must evolve with the times
things that happen online are very real
and they have real implications and we
hear stories from time to time about
cyber bullying and harassment leading to
real-world consequences including
suicide there are real harms there there
are women in particular people who
experience real harms based on malicious
invasions of their privacy
now usually privacy is handled by civil
law in almost every state it is already
civilly unlawful to intentionally cause
emotional distress in a way that is
extremely harmful to someone and is done
maliciously it is already civilly
unlawful as a general matter to invade
someone's privacy in an intentional and
malicious way almost every state has a
privacy tort of that kind but one of the
poles with that is access to the to the
courthouse is expensive the
transactional cost can be expensive
frequently we find that the people that
are involved in this kind of activity
are young and they're just getting out
there started professionally they may
not have the resources to go retain an
attorney you know for thirty five or
thirty five hundred four thousand five
thousand dollars that's unfortunately a
really big issue that applies to so many
areas of the law and by no means unique
to revenge porn that global difficulty
justifies turning civil laws into
criminal laws just doesn't pass the
giggle test right it's expensive to get
a divorce that doesn't mean we make it
illegal to be in a bad marriage Roland
is concerned that the broad law will
criminalize what is normal and
constitute
only protected Internet behavior the
viewing and sharing of nudity one of the
really troubling aspects of the Virginia
law is that it includes criminalization
of posting photographs when the person
isn't authorized to post that photograph
that's an inherently vague term it begs
as many questions as it answers and so
while the criminal law certainly can
grapple with intent
there are many criminal laws that
include an intent element and in fact
it's necessary and most criminal laws to
make sure you're aiming at bad actors
the Virginia law has language that's
frankly pretty mushy and figuring out
whether someone fits into that intent
and whether they're authorized or not to
show that photograph that creates those
problems under the First Amendment where
somebody doesn't necessarily know from
looking at the picture online the
context in which that picture was taken
however Simon Says the courts will be
able to distinguish the difference we
sort of live in a CSI generation where
people sometimes think you need to have
a absolute piece of physical evidence to
prove a case but a lot of cases are
gonna be proved by circumstantial
evidence as a general matter I'm always
very skeptical when the answer to
concerns about the breath or
subjectiveness of a criminal law are met
with responses that oh don't worry about
it prosecutors will use their good
judgment or will figure out from the
circumstances whether or not somebody's
a bad guy right the criminal law is a
blunt instrument and in order to use it
correctly and well it needs to be clear
it needs to be narrowly targeted to the
kind of malicious behavior that
legislators are trying to stop I am
truly concerned that the new wave of
revenge porn laws will create far more
problems than solutions
you